[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es eine Eistorte mit frischen Beeren.
Sehr lecker, supereinfach in der Herstellung.
Denn, ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt echt nur
zehn Minuten Zubereitungszeit.
Und den Rest erledigt dann der Gefrierschrank.
Ich wollte fast Backofen sagen.
Aber nein, heute bleibt der Backofen kalt.
Für die Grundmasse nehme ich
etwas Quark,
Puderzucker,
Vanilleextrakt
und Sahne
und habe hier meine vier Früchte.
Ich nehme Blaubeeren,
Himbeeren,
Brombeeren
und Erdbeeren.
Und keinen Eisbären.
Haha.
Okay.
Ihr macht das jetzt so:
Ihr braucht einfach nur einen Mixer oder einen Stabmixer.
Also irgendwie müsst ihr halt die Früchte zerkleinern.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt alles im Mixer zubereiten,
das heißt auch erst mal die Eisgrundmasse.
Ich gebe jetzt den Quark da rein.
Dann kommt hier Puderzucker dazu.
Etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Dii-di-di!
Da kommt die Sahne dazu.
Und die sieht bei mir immer so ein bisschen flockig und
– ja, sieht ein bisschen flockig aus.
Denn ich habe so eine Bio-Sahne
und da setzt sich eben der Rahm ganz gerne mal oben ab.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Und jetzt einfach kurz durchmixen.
Ihr seht schon, ihr müsst keine Sahne steif schlagen.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir hier vier Becher
und fülle sie gleichmäßig mit der Masse.
Das heißt, einfach die Masse vierteln.
Ich wasche den aus, damit ich ein schönes Bild habe.
Okay.
Jetzt hier schön gleichmäßig aufteilen.
Beim Messbecher habe ich jetzt natürlich den Vorteil,
dass ich es abmessen kann.
Also ich kann es ablesen, wie voll es ist.
Oder ihr stellt Schälchen auf eine Waage.
Oder ihr lebt nach Augenmaß.
[Musik]
Und jetzt gebt ihr hier einfach eure Früchte rein.
Wenn ihr nur drei Früchte nehmt,
dann müsst ihr es eben nur dritteln.
Ich habe jetzt hier frische Erdbeeren
bereits vom Grün befreit.
Brombeeren.
Das ist echt...
Das ist die einzige Frucht,
die hier nicht bei mir im Garten wächst.
Also das muss ich noch ändern.
Irgendwo muss noch ein Brombeerstrauch hin.
Himbeeren.
Und Blaubeeren habe ich auch im Garten.
Aber ich muss euch sagen,
dass ich hier gerne Blaubeeren aus dem TK nehme.
Denn Blaubeeren wurden ja irgendwann gezüchtet.
Das heißt, das hier ist so die Urform.
Die sind außen blau und innen blau.
Aber da war einfach das Problem,
wenn man sie gegessen hat, hat man richtig blaue Finger,
einen blauen Mund und alles bekommen.
Und dann hat man sie praktisch
farbfrei gezüchtet,
also diese Kulturheidelbeeren gezüchtet,
die außen blau sind, aber innen nicht.
Das heißt, die kann man essen
und bekommt dann keinen blauen Mund
und keine blauen Finger.
Die wachsen auch bei uns im Garten.
Aber gerade, wenn ich Torten backe und Cremes herstelle,
nehme ich die,
weil ich einfach eine richtig tolle Farbe bekomme
ohne Farbstoff.
Das ist wirklich so die natürliche Süße,
die natürliche Farbvielfalt,
diese Farbpracht.
Deswegen gehe ich da jetzt auch nicht mit den Fingern rein.
Denn dann habe ich bis heute Abend blaue Hände.
So.
Und jetzt werde ich Folgendes tun.
Ich werde jetzt hier einfach nacheinander
die Creme mit den Früchten pürieren.
Wirklich jede Frucht für sich alleine,
damit sich die Farben nicht vermischen.
Ich möchte einfach, dass das Eis nicht nur lecker schmeckt,
sondern toll aussieht.
Wenn euch die Optik egal ist,
dann püriert alles miteinander.
Dann müsst ihr auch keine vier Förmchen füllen und trennen.
Dann habt ihr einfach eine bunte, fruchtige Eismasse.
[Musik]
Ich fülle sie dann jetzt einfach noch mal zurück
und kann kurz alles durchpürieren.
Und wer möchte, kann auch gern
den Becher dann kurz ausspülen,
damit sich wirklich hier
am Anfang schon mal nichts vermischt.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ich gebe bei den Blaubeeren gleich
noch einen Spritzer Zitronensaft dazu.
Denn jetzt habe ich ja hier schon ein dunkles Lila
von den Brombeeren.
Und die Blaubeeren, die werden so leicht pink,
wenn man so ein bisschen Zitronensaft dazu gibt.
Dann kann ich da nämlich eine andere Farbe erzeugen.
Deswegen spüle ich es da jetzt nicht aus.
[Musik]
Ja.
Das ist mir zu ähnlich.
Da gebe ich noch ein bisschen Zitronensaft dazu.
[Musik]
Gleich ganz anders, gell?
Das war ein Lifehack!
Und noch ein Lifehack:
Wenn ihr jetzt blaue Finger habt von den Blaubeeren,
nehmt ihr einfach die ausgedrückte Zitrone,
gebt eure Finger hier rein
und dann sind sie wieder schön weiß.
Könnt ihr auch so allgemein immer wieder machen.
Dann habt ihr schöne weiße Fingernägel vorne.
Noch ein Lifehack!
Und den Rest in die Spülmaschine als Spülmaschinendeo!
O mein Gott!
So viele Lifehacks!
Ich hätte jetzt zum Befüllen auch eine Silikonform,
so eine längliche,
aber ich zeige euch, wie ihr das machen könnt,
wenn ihr jetzt nur so eine Glasform zum Beispiel habt.
Da braucht ihr jetzt einfach ein bisschen Frischhaltefolie,
damit das Eis sich später gut rausstürzen lässt.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt,
könnt ihr wunderbar eine Silikonform nehmen.
Denn da bekommt man das Eis wunderbar raus.
Aber so geht das auch gut.
Einfach nur darauf achten, dass ihr es schön flach hinlegt.
Jetzt könnt ihr es entweder so machen,
dass ihr die eine Schicht einfüllt, einfriert
und, sobald die gefroren ist,
die nächste drauf, noch mal frieren.
Oder ihr macht es einfach mit so ein bisschen Farbverlauf,
dass es sich so ein bisschen vermischt.
So werde ich es jetzt machen.
Also ich gebe jetzt hier eine Schicht rein.
Dann ein bisschen Rosa.
Dann Lila.
Oh, ich glaube, es wäre auch richtig cool gewesen,
immer in die Mitte gießen.
Und dann hat man...
Wow!
Ja.
Wenn man es immer in die Mitte gießt,
dann hat man in der Mitte später so dieses
wie so einen Zebrakuchen.
[Musik]
Meine Schüssel hat übrigens ein Fassungsvermögen von
etwas mehr als 1600 Millilitern.
Deswegen habe ich hier
die Menge auch direkt ausgerechnet.
Passt perfekt rein.
Eine Minirest ist noch übrig.
Aber das friere ich mir
in so einem Minieiswürfelbehälter einfach ein.
Oh! Ich könnte daraus auch Minieiswürfelchen machen.
Denn dann habt ihr so Snacks,
so Eiswürfel-Konfetti.
Könnt ihr auch machen.
Also das wird jetzt eingefroren, bis es komplett fest ist.
Und dann überlege ich mir noch,
ob ich einen Crunch-Boden mache oder halt nicht.
Mal gucken.
[Musik]
Vor lauter Konfetti im Kopf!
Ich meine natürlich Eiskonfekt,
nicht Eiswürfel-Konfetti.
Eiskonfekt.
[Musik]
Das Eis ist jetzt gefroren.
Und ich nehme es jetzt hier raus.
Hier direkt auf eine Platte.
Ich bin jetzt echt gespannt, wie es schmeckt
und wie es aussieht.
Wenn es nicht gleich geht,
einfach warmes Wasser darüberfließen lassen.
Aber ich probiere es mal kurz ohne.
Nein, es geht nicht.
Da, muss ich halt sagen,
sind Silikonformen dankbarer.
Aber mit etwas Geduld kriegen wir es auch hier raus.
Denn ich habe hier beim Einfüllen nicht aufgepasst.
Da ist die Frischhaltefolie einfach runtergerutscht.
Ich lasse es stehen so lange, bis es rausflutscht.
Aber ich kann euch zeigen,
wie toll das Eiskonfekt hier rauskommt.
Denn da habe ich ja die Eiswürfelförmchen.
Guckt mal!
Geht das geschmeidig!
Wunderbar!
[Musik]
Also bei so Sachen feiere ich Silikon dann schon hart.
Da kriegt ihr wirklich das Eis perfekt raus.
Ich warte einfach ganz kurz
und zeige euch gleich, wie es ausgelöst aussieht,
ein bisschen angetaut.
Ah!
[Musik]
Jetzt packe ich das hier rüber.
Ich habe es mit etwas Gewalt rausgekriegt.
Weil ich habe einfach
dieses Gitter
unter das Wasser gestellt,
habe Wasser darauflaufen lassen, ein bisschen geklopft
und dann ging es.
Ihr könnt aber auch einfach zwei, drei Minuten warten
und dann geht es auch von alleine.
So
ist das Eis eigentlich schon fertig.
Aber ich will es jetzt noch dekorieren.
Das heißt, ich gebe jetzt hier noch Früchte drauf.
Frische Brombeeren habe ich jetzt heute keine mehr.
Aber ich nehme die gefrorenen,
dekoriere das hier so drauf
und drunter
und drüber
und daneben.
Ich finde bei Erdbeeren,
also die muss man, finde ich, einfach anschneiden,
weil die dann hübsch sind,
so richtig schön.
Die werden jetzt auch beim Anschnitt runterfallen, aber
so für den Gesamteindruck finde ich das schon immer schön.
Einmal anrichten und dann anschneiden.
So.
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch weiße Schokoröllchen drauf.
Die mache ich jetzt hier aus Kuvertüre
mit einem Sparschäler.
Es war...
Es war die perfekte Rolle
und dann fällt die einfach runter!
Ich glaube es ja wohl nicht!
[Musik]
Hach!
Oh, ist die schön!
Ja, ich finde es auch schön, wenn sie so daneben liegen.
So.
Ruby Drops.
Josh, wir packen noch Ruby Drops drauf.
Das ist jetzt ein Eis de luxe.
[Musik]
Okay, Sarah, komm!
Like ice in the sunshine!
>> SARAH: Like ice in the sunshine!
>> SALLY: It's melting
>> SALLY & SARAH: away
>> SARAH: on this rainy
>> SALLY & SARAH: day!
>> SALLY: There is no sun, but there is some ice cream!
>> SARAH: Wir sind in den Farben des Eises.
Ich bin die Schokolade.
Fast.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, du bist farbenblind.
>> SARAH: Nee!
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> SARAH: Aber du bist voll in der Farbe!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay.
Okay, vielleicht hätte ich kein Kuchenmesser nehmen sollen,
sondern ein richtiges Messer.
Ich dachte, es geht geschmeidig.
Aber es ist ja gefroren.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe nur das Problem, wenn ich...
>> SARAH: Hat Eis so an sich.
>> SALLY: Warte mal. Ich hole ein Schneidebrett.
Weil das Problem ist, immer diese Dekoschalen...
Jetzt ist die ja so...
>> SARAH: Aber es sieht sehr schön aus!
>> SALLY: Ja, es sieht richtig schön aus.
Aber das ist jetzt so tief da drin und jetzt muss ich es
hier rausheben.
>> SARAH: Eine Fruchtbombe.
>> SALLY: Ja, überspiele es mal. Rede weiter. Überspiele.
>> SARAH: Muss man das nicht warm machen, das Messer?
>> SALLY: Nee.
Also mit einem scharfen Messer geht es.
Das ist halt nur so ein stumpfes Kuchenmesser.
>> SARAH: Cool! Was ist das für ein Messer?
>> SALLY: Das ist eher für Sahnetorten und Trockenkuchen.
>> SARAH: Ah!
>> SALLY: Und das ist ein?
>> SARAH: Masuta.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut, Sarah.
>> JOSH: Das ist kein Masuta.
>> SALLY: Ist das ein Nakiri?
>> SARAH: Ist das ein Nakiri?
Ich verwechsel die immer.
Für mich sieht das
aus wie ein Masuta.
>> SALLY: Wow, wow, wow!
Wow!
>> SARAH: Das ist ja voll das Riesenstück!
>> SALLY: Ja, bitte.
>> SARAH: Vielen Dank!
>> SALLY: Ich habe mir gedacht, dass...
Gönne dir!
>> SARAH: Ich gönne mir.
Ich weiß nur nicht wie.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Okay, jetzt müssten wir es
ein bisschen auftauen lassen.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: So ein bisschen.
>> SARAH: Ich habe das Gefühl, mir hängt das gleich im Pulli.
>> SALLY: Hier, nimm dir von mir.
>> SARAH: Ich bräuchte vielleicht noch mal dein Messer.
Ich nehme von dir.
Das ist zu dick.
>> SALLY: Oh, ist das lecker!
>> SARAH: Ja?
>> SALLY: Hm!
>> SARAH: Wow!
Weißt du, an was mich das erinnert?
Darf man Marken nennen?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß, was du sagst.
Warte!
Sie sagt "Fruchtzwerge".
Hm?
>> SARAH: Fruchtzwerge-Eis.
Hast du das gesagt?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Voll!
Aber in gesund, nehme ich mal an.
>> SALLY: Ja, ein bisschen Zucker ist schon drin, aber
trotzdem nicht so viel Zucker wie in Fruchtzwerge.
Mmh!
>> SARAH: Ich habe das als Kind geliebt!
>> SALLY: Oh, diesen...
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und wir hatten nie diese Stiele
und dann haben wir einfach so türkische Teelöffel,
>> SARAH: Hm. Wir haben auch Löffel genommen.
>> SALLY: so Espressolöffel einfach so rein.
Und dann – o Gott – dieses Eis!
>> SARAH: Weil es waren ja nicht an jedem Fruchtzwerg
solche Eisstiele dran.
>> SALLY: Nee, nee.
Das war immer nur im Sommermonat.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann hatten die so komische Figuren.
>> SARAH: Ah!
>> SALLY: Man muss
fairerweise sagen, es ist nicht das cremigste Eis.
Aber
man hat es ja auch ohne Rühren.
Also normalerweise,
wenn man ein cremiges Eis haben möchte,
muss man vorher
eine Eier-Sahne-Milch-Masse erwärmen und cremig rühren
und dann entweder in einen Eisbereiter reingeben
oder halt im Gefrierschrank und dann immer wieder rühren.
Das ist einfach ein Schichteis, was man eben so einfriert,
ganz schnell gemacht ist
und man hat eben keine Arbeit.
>> SARAH: Und schön fruchtig.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und schön erfrischend.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Also ich finde es auch gut.
Das heißt, wenn ihr es nachmachen wollt,
probiert es gern mal aus.
Das Rezept gibt es auf sallys-blog.de oder in meiner App.
Die Sarah kämpft sich hier jetzt noch durch das Eis durch,
weil sie nicht warten kann, bis es ein bisschen auftaut
oder antaut.
>> SARAH: Ja. Dazu ist es zu lecker.
>> SALLY: Ich kämpfe mich auch durch.
Ja, komm. Wir teilen es so.
Tschakk, tschakkalaka, yeah!
>> SARAH: Wie?
>> SALLY: Tschakkalaka.
>> SARAH: Wir teilen es tschakkalaka.
>> SALLY: Ach, ich sehe schon wieder die nächste Headline:
"Sally teilt ihr Eis tschakkalaka mit ihrer..."
>> SARAH: Was bin ich eigentlich?
Was mache ich eigentlich hier?
>> SALLY: Ich sage es nicht.
Tschüss! Bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> SALLY: "... Backgroundsängerin"
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm. Hm.
>> SARAH: Hm.
[Musik]